by joining us now to discuss all of
tonight's breaking news White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders Sarah good
to see you is the president of any
reaction new Acacio Cortez currently the
congresswoman's prediction Millennials
think like we're like the world is going
to end in 12 years if we don't address
climate change any official White House
position look I don't think we're gonna
listen to her on much of anything
particularly not on matters that are
we're gonna leave into the hands of a
much much higher authority and certainly
not listen to the freshman congresswoman
on when the world may end we're focused
on what's happening in the world right
now we wish that Democrats like herself
would engage in that conversation help
us fix some of the current problems we
know exist and work with us to get some
things done particularly on the border
fixing the national and humanitarian
crisis that's the kind of stuff we're
focused on not things that we're gonna
leave up to the hands of something and
someone much more powerful than any of
us all right let's go to the issue the
the shutdown where we are the president
made a proposal to the Democrats by the
way they did they were ejected it before
was even or some of them rejected before
they even heard what was in it but these
are supposed to be things that the
Democrats like dreamers dakka dakka
kids etc on top of 45 years ago all the
Democrats were in favor of building the
wall and sounded like the president but
yet they have been offered one
invitation after another they refused to
sit down they send aids and surrogates
instead of themselves sitting down at
this point it seems like the president
will have to just go it alone but do you
have any news about that on any front
look Sean I certainly hope the president
has to go it alone one thing I do know
is that Republicans have been in
lockstep with the president because we
actually believe in getting something
done the fact that Democrats went out
before the president even put his
proposal forward on Saturday and
rejected it shows us exactly where they
are and that is that they're not looking
to solve problems but they're simply
looking to kick the can down the road
obstruct any progress being
whether it's on this issue or probably
anything else we've seen no indication
that Democrats want to work with with
the president to actually fix the
problems facing this country I think
it's a sad day in America when Nancy
Pelosi rejects an idea before she's even
heard it but unfortunately I think that
she's showing us exactly who she is what
her priorities are and that's not the
American people the only person in this
process and in this back-and-forth that
is actually doing something to help the
800,000 federal workers that's actually
doing something to stop the opioid
crisis stop human trafficking stop the
national security crisis at our border
is the president Democrats claim to care
about these people claim to want to fix
problems yet they don't want to do
anything about it they want to ignore
the problem and attack the president and
I think that is a very very sad day and
I think it shows us what a leader is and
what a leader isn't the president's a
leader and Nancy Pelosi is nothing more
than an obstructionist let's go to the
latest State of the Union address where
are we there Nancy Pelosi invited the
president he accepted she cited concerti
concerns as a potential reason to delay
that the United States Secret Service
and DHS have addressed those concerns
and we're moving forward until something
changes on that front was will the
president consider other options if the
house is not open to her I don't know
where you're going to be able to get at
least 535 members of Congress and
invited guests you know in Washington
I'm sure there's a place but I just
don't know where that is I don't know if
there would be a place that all of those
members would attend but the president's
focuses on speaking to the American
people it's something he does every
single day nobody does it better and if
Nancy Pelosi chooses to go in that
direction the president will continue to
speak to the American people and I'm
sure he'll do that on that evening as
well all right let me ask you about that
what happened Friday with BuzzFeed and
if it's true you had literally every
major newspaper every single Network
so-called news channels over 200 times
go for if it's true and then spend hours
after hour after hour saying impeachment
without any verification on their own
cheryl atkinson has a list of 67 media
mistakes in the trump era the definitive
list I printed out literally 47 small
print pages of the Washington Examiner
of mistakes the media is made in their
reporting about the president in one
year alone and that would be 2017 his
reaction to it and does now the
president's branding of fake news is
that forever etched into the minds of
the American people when they see events
like this on Friday and then followed by
covington and what happened to those
students honestly Sean we hope not we
hope fake news doesn't become the
forever brand of the news media because
it's not good for the country as the
president said he'd love for people to
report things accurately I think what
happened with BuzzFeed is a great lesson
for the media quit trying to be first
and start trying to be right we've seen
time and time again where they run out
there with these outrageous ridiculous
stories one person reports it to begin
with and then they all jump on it we saw
it again with the Covington students
I've never seen people so happy to
destroy a kid's life when that becomes
the norm in the media in America simply
because they're associated with this
president that is disgraceful and that
should never happen let's hope that this
is a lesson to all of the media to
everyone let's focus on getting things
right not getting them first all right
Sarah thank you so much for being with
us